a huddled Mass displaced desperate and
on the move
they survived an earthquake
[Music]
but look at the toll it's taken
many here fled Wharf only to see their
lives ripped apart in Turkey now they're
headed back but to more destruction and
more Danger
yeah
summer here at babalhauer Crossing to
bring back bodies to Grant families the
gift of a goodbye yeah
Hussein is among them but on the other
side he too has lost
I'm going to Syria because my older
brother died I'm going to the cemetery
a funeral after days spent trying to
save others
this is you going in here yeah
you saved one man my brother brought
nearly 100 bodies here to the Border too
and we took kids to the hospital aren't
you worried about the danger of
returning to Syria there's no fear left
no fear at all
many are now Homeless looking for
shelter in their Homeland refugees
restarting life yet again but it's a
journey of real Jeopardy ahead
sir yes we're afraid to go back to Syria
and here we're afraid the house may fall
on us
these una trucks are on their way to the
rebel held Northwest but they're playing
catch up and many more are needed
in idlib little Aslan is now an orphan
he's two years old and doctors are
saving his leg from being amputated
[Music]
the rubble in Haram
covered in dust ice ice
Aslan is the sole survivor in his family
back at the border they cross from bad
to far far worse and yet they believe
it's their best chance of getting any
help
Sky News on the turkey Syrian border